the mother of reality star Whitney Way
Thor has died she was 76. stop Mom did
you even look that was not even a full
stop mom you rolled through there I did
not I did her mother Barbara known to
fans as Babs was a staple on Whitney's
series my big fat fabulous life I tried
to do a lot of new things
um with my dad like you can see us doing
Taekwondo I took my mom swimming I think
that this is something you should do on
the regular maybe not worthy pantyhose
next time
but I'm impressed Mommy and I'm proud of
you Whitney shared the tragic news to
Instagram alongside this sweet video
tribute you're just a gift is what you
are I know
modest too I know the reality series
documented Barbara's Health struggles
it's way car
over the past few years she suffered a
series of Strokes the most recent one
last month we've been married almost 45
years
and such a wonderful wife and a
wonderful mother and I didn't I had no
idea how I was going to go forward if
she wasn't around
Whitney writes quote I am the luckiest
person on the planet to have been hers
for almost 39 years into her fans Winnie
thanks them for quote loving her mother
when I hear from a lot of fans that say
you know your family is so amazing and
your family's so supportive and no
wonder you know you're happy and
everything just look at your family and
it's true quote she delighted in her
Newfound television career more than we
can describe and it is our hope that her
memory will continue to be a source of
comfort and happiness for the rest of
your lives just as it will be for ours
foreign